it must two
okay
good up there man
so
sleep
briefing will begin in two minutes
so
so
so good afternoon i have an announcement
for you on hospital funding as
appropriated in the third phase of
coronavirus relief
the trump administration will distribute
a total of 12 billion dollars in
provider relief fund payments to 395
hospitals
across the country that have been
hardest hit by the covid19 pandemic
these hospitals have collectively cared
for over 70 percent
of the 184 000 americans that required
hospital
and patient care 10 billion of the 12
billion will go towards hospitals
treating 100 or more
covid19 admissions hhs is distributing
an additional 2 billion dollars to these
395 hospitals
in proportion to the amount of care they
provide to low-income
and uninsured patients this is
consistent with our effort to ensure
that americans who need federal
government assistance the most
receive it we'll be releasing a
breakdown of the states receiving this
funding and the counties receiving this
funding before your awareness
new york new jersey and illinois receive
the most funding by state
while new york new york bronx new york
and cook illinois receive the most
funding by county as determined by our
metrics
our health care providers as president
trump has repeatedly acknowledged our
heroes as we work to defeat the
invisible enemy
this relief funding will help these
heroes defeat this virus
in reacting to care's relief i love what
this one provider said
so he said thank you and god thank you
and god for this relief i have tears in
my eyes out of gratitude for these funds
thank you so so so much additionally 100
flights as part of project airbridge
have been completed to date
these flights have expedited nearly 1
billion pieces of ppe for our healthcare
heroes
the third phase of coronavirus relief
also included 320 billion dollars in
additional funding for the paycheck
protection program which
as you all know provides forgivable
loans to small businesses in order to
keep their employees on payroll
this program has been extraordinarily
successful during the first round of ppp
loans 1.6 million loans were issued to
small businesses
of those 1.6 million loans 1 million of
them were given to companies with 10 or
fewer employees
so it has gone to small businesses and
businesses that need it most
but the ppp look it's not just another
government program
this is supporting everyday americans
who through no fault of their own have
found themselves in this predicament
we saw this firsthand at the white house
on tuesday on tuesday president trump
welcomed small business owners and
employees to the white house
these small businesses received ppp
loans which helped them pay their
employees during the pandemic
bidding bose was among the small
businesses welcome to the white house
biddy and bose employs 120 people with
intellectual and developmental
disabilities it's a
coffee shop not too far away from here
vidi ambos had to temporarily close its
doors but because of ppp
loans bitty bose was able to rehire all
of its employees
i might have the real honor of getting
to meet michael hoyp
he's one of the employees at biddies and
biddy and bows and he offered some words
of
encouragement to our country um and they
really touched my heart and i think
they'll touch the heart of them of
america if you guys wouldn't mind
playing those remarks
you president trump and ivanka thanks a
lot for inviting us
thank you mr president for having us i
love my job and i am excited about going
back to work
at billion votes we like to use the
phrase
called not broken that means me and all
my
amazing coworkers are not broken and we
have less to offer
i know the great country of the united
states
isn't broken either so on behalf of
myself
megan and amy and all the employees of
being involved thank you for inviting us
over
you guys are our family
michael's an incredible young man i gave
him a call yesterday and asked him what
he was up to and he said he and his
fellow employees were
literally handwriting notes uh to put in
uh with their coffee packages that they
send out to consumers
i receive one of these notes from
another company and it really does put a
smile on your face and
michael's doing that each and every day
and biddy and bose they represent the
hope and opportunity that is on the
horizon for america's workers
as their body their their business
rather embodies the american spirit
workers like michael show that this
country is not broken
and that we will recover together
michael
thank you you're an american hero thank
you for sharing that message of hope and
with that i'll take questions
kelly if i could and welcome to the
podium for the first time thank you
as well uh the markets are down
substantially today after the president
yesterday
suggested in the eastern that he might
use tariffs to punish china
over the coronavirus is is there any
serious consideration being given to
putting new tariffs on china or was the
president just
spitballing yesterday look i won't get
ahead of any announcements from the
president but i will echo the
president's displeasure with china
it's no secret that china mishandled
this situation
just a few examples for you they did not
share the genetic sequence
until a professor in shanghai did so on
his own the very next day
china shut down his lab for quote
rectification
they slow walked information on human to
human transmission alongside the world
health organization and didn't let
u.s investigators in at a very important
time so
we take displeasure with china's actions
but i certainly won't get ahead of the
president with those announcements
is the president seriously considering
forcing china to pay some sort of
compensation
reparations whatever word you want to
put on it again when it comes to
retaliatory measures um i will not get
ahead of the president on that
thank you kaylee and welcome to the
podium as well
the president said yesterday that he has
a high degree
of confidence that the coronavirus
originated in a lab in wuhan china and
yet his
own intelligence agencies say they're
still investigating so
does the president have information and
has he drawn a conclusion that the
intelligence community has not yet
well the president's statement is
consistent with the other intelligence
assessments
while we continue to have very limited
and dubious data from china current
assessments indicated that president
trump's statement is consistent
with what some analysts believe is the
epicenter of where the virus began and i
would note
that intelligence statement you're
referring to really made two points one
that this virus originated in china uh
two that it began
through contact with infected animals or
was the result of an accident at a
laboratory in wuhan
uh so i consider that consistent with
what the president said that he's seen
intelligence suggesting
it could be in the wilhelm laboratory
lean
into the idea that this started in a
laboratory whereas the statement that we
saw
from the dni said we're still
investigating those two options that you
just laid out
is the president in any way creating
mixed messaging by not saying
we're still investigating no you know
let me remind everyone intelligence is
just
an estimate essentially and it's up to
policymakers to decide what to do with
that intelligence
this in this case the policymaker is the
president of the united states and he'll
make that decision at the right time
president any close to deciding what to
do about china
has he received any recommendations of
the consequences
is he anywhere near a decision look
again i won't get ahead of the
president's decision or the timing of
that decision but he takes this very
seriously because
the decisions of china that i referenced
slow walking some of that information
put american lives at risk
and rest assured this president has one
priority
and that is the safety and the
well-being of american lives
thank you so much haley welcome um since
it's been more than 100 days since the
press secretary stood up there i wanted
to get a better sense of what your plan
is are you planning to do these
in a daily basis at this point and also
um will you pledge never to lie to us
from that podium i will never lie to you
you have my word on that
as to the timing of the briefings um we
do plan to do them um
i will announce timing of that
forthcoming but we do plan to continue
these
welcome to the to the podium a question
for you about project
work work speed can you give us some
more details
the president said ultimately he's in
charge of this project but will there be
a day-to-day
point person on this what's the budget
for this project and when
can the american people realistically
expect that there will be a
a vaccine available to everybody well
there is a day-to-day point person and
that's the president of the united
states president trump
and with regard to vaccines i would note
the words of dr
fauci which are these going into a phase
one trial within three months of getting
the sequence is unquestionable
the world indoor record nothing has ever
gone this fast so what the president is
doing and under the president's
leadership uh we're in phase one faster
than ever before according to dr falchi
and that should encourage the american
people
in the budget and the budget and then
there's really no other point person i
mean i know the president ultimately i
guess the buck stops with the president
but
he hasn't put us somebody on the on the
staff i'm not
yeah i'm not going to get into any
details as to exactly how that works but
just rest assured
we're on an accelerated pace to a
vaccine at least for this phase one
portion of clinical trial um
thanks the the fed yesterday took an
action that appeared designed to allow
oil companies to
access their landing facilities so i'm
wondering if the president has spoken to
chairman powell about this
uh if he's happy about the move uh and
if the white house is considering any
additional assistance to the oil
companies
so i won't get into the president's
personal discussions but i would just
note
that the president is always looking out
for the nearly 11 million american
workers in the oil industry
i would also note that we're filling the
strategic petroleum reserve right now
and we'll buy 75 million barrels so
that's the only announcements i have on
the oil front today
yes hollow today thank you kaylee
the president tweeted this morning about
the protest in michigan
he essentially said that the governor of
michigan should work with the protesters
she called them very good people
and said that they are very angry some
of those protests i'm sure you saw
included you know heavily armed
protesters members of militia groups
i wonder if the president was speaking
about those specific members who
stormed the capital in michigan when he
talked about very good people
look the president was referencing
generally that in this country
you have a first amendment right to
protest i think that's something we all
treasure here
um and we should rightfully you have a
right to do that constitutionally but
you must protest within the bounds of
the law
um he encourages everyone to protest
lawfully
and also to engage in our social
distancing guidelines which we think all
americans should engage in if you have
any response to just the imagery of
you know people with long guns
essentially storming the capital going
into face-offs with police officers and
intimidating in some ways some of the
lawmakers again the president says you
know that we must protest lawfully and
act within the bounds of the law
yes thank you for being here uh when the
president says we did a spectacular job
when jared kushner talks about a great
success story
some americans see it as a lack of
empathy what's
uh do you understand their reaction look
you know jared kushner
has first of all done a great job for
this administration and
what i would say to that is that his
when he talked about a success story
he was talking about the story of this
administration which is a story of
mobilization for the american people the
greatest mobilization
of american industry since world war ii
um
of course we grieve for every american
life that has been lost
but we want the american people to be
confident in the response of this
administration and that is what he was
referring to the fact that
in the average year the healthcare
industry uses 25
million and 95 masks and we have
delivered in this short time
75 million in 95 mass more than three
times
what the healthcare sector uses in a
year that's extraordinary it's
extraordinary that
you know some in the media were saying
that we needed a million ventilators and
uh this president has we haven't we've
needed far short of that so far not not
a single american has died for lack of a
ventilator and the fact that this
president
can look the american people in the eye
and say i am producing a hundred
thousand
ventilators this year alongside the
private sector
hundred thousand ventilators that's
three times what we produce in the
average year
i'd consider that a great success on
behalf of the american people
it's more about the tone the the policy
itself we want to give the american
people confidence that they have a
federal government
that is doing everything in our power to
provide the necessary equipment to
convert to combat this invisible enemy
we grieve for the american lives we've
said that repeatedly i i will echo that
today my heart breaks for those i
pray regularly for those who are
affected by the coronavirus but we're
going to give confidence to the american
people that you have a federal
government under president
donald trump that's going to step up and
give the greatest mobilization of the
private sector
since world war ii yeah thank you so
much kaylee thanks for being here
president trump mentioned the situation
in brazil a few times this week
besides talks of cutting off flights
from brazil
are there talks of in terms of sending
assistance to brazil sending ppe or
ventilators to brazil
and is president trump planning to talk
with president personally
well the president has mentioned that he
has sent ventilators
around the world any excess supply we
certainly look to help other countries
but you know in terms of a specific
announcement regarding brazil i don't
have any new information for you
on that front today yeah kelly um
welcome
one of the most important parts of your
job though is to have access to the
president can you give us
some indication that since you've been
named press secretary
what kind of access do you have to the
president to get what he's thinking
and relay it to us yeah i can tell you
this i'm around the president almost the
entire day i was just with him before i
left to come out and speak with you guys
i think my staff can attest to the fact
that they have a very hard time finding
me because i'm normally
with the president and the oval office
so i am consistently with him
absorbing his thinking and it's my
mission uh to bring you the mindset of
the president deliver those facts so
this president gets fair and accurate
reporting and the american people get
fair and accurate
information yeah thanks kaylee just
following up on kristen's question
china's blocking the world health
organization from coming in
and investigating how this started
shouldn't external investigators be
allowed
into wuhan to determine one how the
pandemic started
and two maybe a way that we could
expedite finding a cure for this thing
look you know there's no secret that
china stopped us investigators from
coming in um it was of
paramount importance that we got into
china in an expedited fashion and that
didn't happen
with respect to world health
organization they have some questions of
their own to answer
uh the united states as the president
has emphasized provides
about 400 million to 500 million per
year to the who compared to china
roughly 40 million a year but yet the
who appears to have a very clear
china bias i mean you look at this
timeline and it's really damning for the
who when you consider the fact that
on december 31st you had taiwanese
officials warning about human to human
transmission
the who did not make that public on
january 9th the who repeated china's
claim that the virus quote does not
transmit readily between people that was
quite apparently false on january 14th
the who again repeated china's talking
points about no human
human transmission they praised china's
leadership on the 22nd of january on the
23rd
they said and this is incredible the
pandemic didn't represent a public
health emergency of international
concern and even on
february 29th you had the who
saying that when the coronavirus was
spreading around the world
they they chose to put excuse me
political correctness first
by opposing life-saving travel
restrictions the travel
restrictions this president put in place
the travel restrictions that dr
fauci praised as saving lives and you
have the world health organization
opposing a measure that saved american
lives that's unacceptable
especially at a time when the us was
providing 400 to 500 million dollars
john haley this time last week the
president was saying that he was not
happy with georgia's governor brian kemp
for
beginning the reopening process and the
way that he was at the time that he was
a week later there have been some peaks
and valleys in new cases in georgia but
overall the trend line is down
do you know what the president's
thinking about the georgia reopening is
as of today
the president the president is resolute
in saying that the states
take the lead here um it's the the lead
the decision of governors to decide what
is best for their state that being said
um you know i've i talked to the experts
i talked to dr burks i talked to dr
fauci and they say rightfully so this
president has always
cited on the side of data which is why
he encourages all states to follow the
data-driven guidelines to reopening
all states from georgia on down the line
should follow those guidelines but
ultimately
it is the decision of the states and one
note i would make about the president in
times of national emergency
we seem to have had a trend in this
country where uh presidents aggregate
power at the federal level
but this president has devolved power
he's invested in a principle that i
cherish and i know many others do which
is federalism and i think that was
the right decision has he mentioned how
he feels about governor camp in the last
few days
i have not spoken to him about governor
kemp in the last few days
as the president on the lives of
reopening as the president
pushes forward to reopen the country
does that mean he'll be campaigning in
those uh states
where he that will be reopening so i
would refer you to the trump campaign on
that
question yeah yeah thanks for being here
kaylee um
you mentioned dr fauci a minute ago are
we gonna have any more
press briefings with dr fauci and dr
burks and the health experts or is the
white house kind of
shifting the message to you know focus
more on the economy and less on the
public health aspect
well let me back up and talk to you a
little bit about how we approach
disseminating information you know when
i talk with my colleague alyssa and we
plan out the communica
communication strategy for this white
house along with the president
um and ben as well you know what we do
is we say what is the best mode for the
public to receive this information at
this time and we allow
the news cycle and the needs of the
american people to guide us and you know
at the moment what we see happening and
i hinted at this in my gaggle last week
is
uh you have 35 states and probably more
at this point with plans to reopen the
country americans are looking
to reopening the country we've had dr
burks in several events this week
they've been
dr burks and falchi out on the airwaves
um they're really incredible people and
have done a great service for this
country
but we allow the uh news of the day to
guide us what the american people
need to hear and right now we're in a
reopening phase which is why you've seen
the president this week with ceos you've
seen him with small business owners with
small business employees today with some
great heroes
that have emerged from this pandemic and
have done a lot of the hard work
so every day we approach this as how can
we disseminate this information there's
a
need for information which is why i'm
here supplementing that the efforts of
this president
to get the message out i would also note
he's the most accessible president in
history took questions twice yesterday
twice the day before
you hear from him quite often as well of
as well as our medical experts so
is the task force still meeting i guess
what's the role of the car buyers task
force we still have
you know hundreds of people a day are
dying so what what
what role does the task force have
versus the economic advisory
yeah the task force meets regularly i go
to those meetings
i hear them we are dr burks i should say
is
meticulously reviewing the data and
granular detail
i watch them spend sometimes the upwards
of two hours in these task force
briefings so those those are still
ongoing rest assured
we want a safe reopening so we are
prioritizing the health of the american
people
um as well as looking forward to
reopening this country
yes thank you kaylee back to the dni
statement from yesterday there is a
quote that i'd like to you to
give me a response to it said the
intelligence community
also concurs with the wide scientific
consensus that the kovid 19 virus
was not man-made or genetically modified
this was from the dni statement how do
you see this
uh statement how do you understand this
and also there was the piece in the
new york times that said senior trump
administration officials have pushed
intelligence agencies to hunt for
evidence
to support the theory that kobit 19 was
made in a wuhan laboratory i can assure
you that no one is
pressing the intelligence community to
come to a determination
the intelligence community statement
stands um it's in perfect concert with
what the president
said um so you know i encourage the
media to
convey the facts to the american people
which is um that we're in line as an
administration and we stand by the
intelligence community and that is
in complete concert with with what the
president said yesterday
[Music]
who haven't i gotten to oh i've gone to
almost everyone okay so we're in round
two
that's great yes thank you today former
vice president joe biden denied
allegations of sexual misconduct
against him does president trump take
him at his word given that as the
president has said he has denied
allegations against himself
well what i would say is that we are
pleased that the former vice president
has decided to go on the record it took
him less than what
16 hours to follow the advice of the
president of the united states and come
out and
publicly address those claims so you
know we're glad to see that he's on the
record on this
ask you about something the president
said moments ago in an interview he said
that
tara reid is quote far more compelling
than anything
they had with respect to brett kavanaugh
what did he mean by that what is more
compelling
you know that's the president's
assessment so i would point you back to
his words i think it was a
grave miscarriage of justice what
happened with justice brett kavanaugh
i there's no need for me to bring up
some of these salacious
awful and verifiably false allegations
that were made against justice kavanaugh
that was an embarrassment for the
democrat party to have dragged the name
of a very respectable man
through the mud like that um so i'll
leave it at that
if kaylee is the radio pooler i'm asking
this on behalf of her
colleague there's word the decision to
release michael cohen
from prison to home confinement due to
cover 19 has been reversed
did the white house directly or
indirectly intervene here
um no so absolutely not i would say
there but i am glad that um
you brought up justice and because look
there's
again a a case of injustice that is yet
to be brought up today but i certainly
would like to bring it up and that's
the case of general michael flynn what
we've all learned from that
should scare every american citizen uh
the fact that you had
jim comey admitting in december of last
year
that he violated a protocol by directing
agents to confront flynn something that
he would not
quote have gotten away with under
previous administrations
the fbi told flynn he didn't need a
lawyer when they came to meet with him
mccabe told fbi agents that he didn't
think flynn was lying and then all of
that information we've learned
over the last few months and years
culminates in the fact that we have a
handwritten fbi
note that says quote we need to get
flynn to lie
quote and get him fired um
that was there was an unfar unfair
target on the back of general michael
flynn
um it should concern every american any
time
there's a partisan pursuit of an
individual and that's certainly
at least those questions are raised with
regard to general michael flynn an
honorable man
who served his country yeah kelly
on that when the president fired michael
flynn uh he said he was doing so because
he had lied to the vice president and he
had lied to the fbi
so given all that you've just said
isn't it isn't it still true doesn't the
president still believe that michael
flynn lied
to vice president pence and lied to the
fbi well first let me address that vice
president pence is on the record about
this he said
he's inclined to believe that flynn did
not intentionally mislead him and i
guess i would turn the question on you
and just ask
does it trouble you that the fbi said uh
we got to get flin to lie doesn't that
trouble you as a journalist and not not
only that as an american citizen
well it's certainly something worth
reporting it's not my job to say whether
or not it's troubling but
but the bottom line is the president
said point blank that flynn lied
to the fbi and to the vice president and
i'm just asking a very direct question
does he still believe
that michael flynn lied to the fbi and
lied to the vice president and again i'd
point you to the vice president's
statement that he's inclined to believe
that flynn did not intentionally mislead
him and i'm asking back
that all of you in your coverage
endeavored to report
what is a very scary story when the fbi
is saying let us get someone to lie i've
seen very scant coverage of that it's a
story worth reporting and a story that i
hope the american people if you haven't
heard it yet
are getting to hear for the very first
time
[Music]
going back to the south china sea we had
an issue come up this morning where you
had
the uss berry crossing international
maritime waters and then china
this is in the south china sea and
chinese officials are saying that this
will be
a dead end endeavor does
has the president spoken with
any of the any side on the chinese
as far as what the united states is
going to continue doing is the u.s may
be going to just
ignore these threats and keep keep going
through these international
waters what are your responses to
china's increasing
aggression in the south china sea again
i have no news to report as to the
president's conversations and for the
specifics of that i would um redirect
you to the nsc
yeah thanks um in the same podcast
interview the president said that
uh democrats would quote have to give us
a lot for aid to
to states i'm wondering if you have any
idea of what specifically the white
house or the president is asking for
and secondly what you'd say to somebody
like governor cuomo
who says you know the president's
already told me you know a few weeks ago
that he would support this type of
assistance
and why are we bailing out you know
airlines or defense contractors but not
the states that play
that pay teachers or first responders
well first you brought up governor cuomo
so i just um
thought it's a good time to remind
everyone that governor cuomo
has praised the president's response um
in this coven 19 crisis saying that what
the president has achieved is a
phenomenal accomplishment and we thank
governor cuomo
um for those very kind words but on that
note with regard to funding to states um
phase four is something that we want to
start negotiating
negotiating on immediately and get to
work on
the president has said look i will
certainly
look to consider helping states who have
corona virus reasons for
the financial situation they find
themselves in but he doesn't want this
to be an excuse for decades and decades
of bad
democrat governance that have run some
of these states into a financial
predicament so he has mentioned
that um in terms of the types of things
he wants to see in this phase four
i don't want to get ahead of the
negotiations but i do want to emphasize
that he has mentioned sanctuary cities
this is a really important issue that
has cost american lives on last year are
brave
ice officers arrested more than 120 000
criminal
aliens charged with nearly ten thousand
burglaries five thousand sexual assaults
forty five thousand violent assaults two
thousand murders
and in the last year egregiously five
thousand human trafficking
episodes so american lives matter our
brave ice men and women matter and it's
something that he's mentioned he'd like
to see
in a phase four i mean you raised that
and the president's been kind of vague
about this
are you explicitly conditioning state
aid
on uh states or cities not saying that
they would
have sanctuary city policies no i'm not
no not conditioning anything but saying
that is a negotiation item that
that the president will certainly uh
bring up
thanks very much um so the president has
in the past denied
any of the allegations from the many
women who have accused him of sexual
misconduct um but for that podcast today
he seemed to suggest the allegations
that tara reid has raised are more would
he say credible
than the ones against brett kavanaugh um
what about the allegations that were
raised against him however why should
the public
or what makes them them any less
credible than the allegations from tara
reed the president has
swiftly denied all of these allegations
that were raised
four years ago he has always told the
truth on these issues
he's denied them immediately and you're
bringing up issues like i said from
four years ago that were asked and
answered and the american people
had their say in the matter when they
elected president trump as president of
the united states but
you know the media leave it to the media
to really take an issue about the former
vice president and turn it on the
president and bring up
accusations from four years ago that
were asked and answered in the form of
the vote of the american people
just come back haley uh to john's
question because kellyanne conway spoke
to this the other day and suggested that
two things could be true at the same
time
we now have the vice president saying
it's his belief
that general flynn may have
unintentionally misled him that's now
three years
after the fact but the two things that
could have been true at the same time
were that flynn lied to the vice
president and also lied to the fbi
if you remove the fbi piece of that
would the president
still have fired michael flynn for his
belief that he lied at that point to the
vice president i mean i'm not going to
engage in a hypothetical and that's
essentially
what that would be but what i would say
is echo yet again
that this was a grave miscarriage of
justice i am very glad that the fbi
thought to keep a paper trail because
what
many have said for a very long time
pointing to the first few facts i shared
with you culminating in that handwritten
note
i'm glad they kept such good
documentation of their intent to slow
walk
general flynn into a trap and to
essentially
create as i mentioned a grave
miscarriage of justice so
fbi at least we can thank you for the
great note-taking
let me follow up on that though john
does bring up the point that general
flynn pleaded guilty
to lying to the fbi i'm not going to get
involved in uh what was
a a matter of justice
do you not consider it a miscarriage of
justice
when you have the fbi writing we want to
get
someone to lie is that a miscarriage of
justice
but in in the end he pleaded guilty and
then that's you hesitated because you
know what the answer is
the answer is yes a lot of other people
and i would encourage the media to cover
it
because i've watched a lot of your
networks i've read a lot of your papers
i've seen a whole lot of scant
information about michael flynn
when there was a whole lot of
speculation about russia russia russia
culminating in 40 million dollars of
taxpayer
money being lost and the complete and
total exoneration of
president trump thank you guys so much
i'm gonna cut this short now and go see
my little five month old here in a few
hours let me just say this
um the president at 5 pm leaves today
for camp david it's going to be
working weekend he'll be talking with
heads of states um with elected
officials we have a great event coming
up this afternoon and
of course um everyone should watch the
fox news town hall with the president
from seven to nine pm it'll be
uh can't miss television much like the
highly rated president trump
uh coronavirus task force briefings have
been thank you
[Music]
my friends and family started reaching
out and mentioning that mount sinai was
running
program we're gonna be starting one up
to see if the you know the plasma the
blood plasma
from recovered coronavirus patients
could have some sort of
uh therapy potential went through
multiple rounds of screening including
being re-swapped having my blood tested
going through screening questions and i
was approved as a prime candidate for
noting donating my blood plasma
uh i was upset i was embarrassed i asked
for
why uh the the relaxed restrictions
weren't being observed here
and it was essentially explained to me
that there was a bureaucratic issue at
play when i asked them for further
clarification it was made clear that
their computers needed to be updated
and that their staff needed to be
retrained
[Music]
there was some confusion understandably
by the public
um when the fda guidance came out
because it did say immediate
implementation
what that means for blood centers is
they can start the process
at that point in time in implementing
these changes and because there are so
many processes and procedures that have
to be changed within a blood center to
comply with the new guidance
that just takes some time we anticipate
that on average it's going to take about
two to three months
we hope to to be able to have these
things done as soon as possible we know
how important
it is um both to the donor sides as well
as most importantly to the patients
who need these blood components
apple and google said this month they
were teaming up to make it possible for
iphones and android phones
to alert their owners if they think
they've been in close proximity with
someone who later tested positive
for covid19 it's called contact tracing
and for the two tech companies it's
become a bit of a controversial endeavor
both firms insist the privacy is
preserved and no personal information
ever leaves an individual's phone
but critics question the privacy
concerns and also whether the tech will
even work effectively at all
here's how apple and google say it
should work let's say there are two
individuals standing in line at a
grocery store we'll call them
taylor and meredith they've never met
before and they never speak while
they're in the store
while they're in there taylor's iphone
generates a string of random letters and
numbers called an identifier
meredith's android phone generates one
too the bluetooth chips in each of their
phones can
tell if they come in close proximity
with each other without needing internet
or gps or wi-fi
or anything that could transfer personal
information it's a little bit like when
you buy a new pair of wireless
headphones
and you turn your phone on and you turn
the headphones on and they can at least
see each other
so meredith and taylor's bluetooth chips
have detected each other and exchanged
their random identifiers
a few minutes later both devices
generate brand new identifiers
and their owners leave the store still
having never spoken
those identifiers stay on their phones
for now so not only are they nonsensical
strings of digits
they're also only stored locally but
let's say a few days later
meredith is positively tested for
covid19
she downloads her local government's
public health authority app
and tells it about the diagnosis in
order to get the latest medical advice
what apple and google are creating is a
way for that app and specifically only
that app
to also ask meredith's permission to
give a contact tracing server
the random identifier numbers that her
phone's generated over the past few days
just those numbers that's it so meredith
agrees
the next day taylor's at home eating the
food she bought from the grocery store
that moment taylor's phone detects that
there's an identifier on the server
that matches one it's seen before in
person a bit like watching a televised
lottery result
where the random numbers drawn on screen
match the ones in a person's hand
on their ticket hopefully the numbers
mean nothing in and of themselves of
course
but because there's a match that means
something specific
taylor's phone has at some point
recently been near a person
who's tested positive for covert 19.
if taylor also has the public health
authorities app her phone can tell the
app a match has occurred and then the
app
can alert her and offer the latest
medical advice
the app never sees the random identifier
that the phone's matched
it just knows that a match has been
found and this is why apple and